“What are those things?” a member
of the exploration team asks,
pointing to hundreds of clear orbs. He
begins moving towards the mysterious objects.
Progress is slow; the bulky spacesuit is meant
to withstand the planet's hostile conditions
but doesn’t allow for much maneuverability.
“They look like canisters containing some
sort of creature,” the SCP agent says.
Dr. Sanders points his headlamp
in the direction of the voice.
“Mother of God,” he whispers into his
helmet. “Stop moving!” he yells. “Are
those eggs? Nothing is supposed to be able
to survive on this planet. That’s why it was
chosen for off-world testing and containment
for the Foundation's deadliest entities.”
The team points their lights at the orbs.
The creatures inside don’t seem to be moving.
They are suspended in some type of gel, and when
the lights hit them, the creatures look like
metallic squids. Dr. Sanders holds up his hand
to signal the rest of the team to stop moving.
“I thought I saw some activity,”
he says. The team looks around,
but they don’t see anything. “I must be jumping
at shadows. Grab the equipment, and let’s get out
of here. We need to contact SCP command and find
out what they want us to do with these things.”
The team packs up their gear and makes their
way out of the cave system beneath the alien
planet's surface. As they exit the mouth of
the cave, they are greeted by a nighttime sky
filled with stars and nebula. The undesignated
planet is located in the deep recesses of space.
The only light on this part of the planet
comes from the suits of Dr. Sander’s team.
Without any light pollution like on Earth, it
seems as if every part of the universe is visible.
“If it wasn’t so creepy here, it’d be kinda
beautiful,” one of the team members says.
All of the SCP agents have stopped
walking and stare up at the cosmos.
“Come on,” says Dr. Sanders.
“Let’s get back to ILYENA and
find out what the O-5 Council wants
us to do with this new discovery.”
The next night the exploration team is back at
the caverns where they discovered the mysterious
orbs the previous evening. Dr. Sanders leads
his team into the winding tunnel system.
It leads directly under one of the largest
mountain ranges on the planet. They approach the
chamber that contains the clear orbs and get to
work collecting samples to bring back to the lab.
“We have no idea what these things actually are,
so be careful. If you see movement, immediately
back away. I want teams of two for each pod. One
person collects the sample; the other holds the
incinerator at the ready just in case you need
to fry whatever is inside of these things.”
The team members confirm their orders and get
to work. Everything goes according to plan.
The samples are gathered, and the SCP
team makes its way out of the caverns.
When they get to the surface, Dr. Sanders
radios to the command center at ILYENA.
“We are out from under the mountain. The
canisters have been secured. Estimated
time to the rover is four minutes.
Will update when en route to base.”
“Roger that extraction team. We will have
the loading bay ready for your arrival,”
responds the communications officer at ILYENA.
Sanders and his crew board the rover and put
the canisters in the storage compartment.
The drive back to ILYENA is uneventful. The
entire planet is basically made up of dust
and rocks. Until yesterday, everyone at ILYENA
thought they were the only living things out here,
other than the few dangerous SCPs they
brought along with them to experiment on.
The rover pulls into the research base and
parks outside the airlock. The team carries
the canisters into the storge dome for further
analysis before heading to decontamination.
Sanders walks out of the airlock and takes off
his helmet. “Breen! We’ve brought back the orbs,
and they are awaiting your analysis in the
storage bay. I don’t know what they are,
but the fact that they might be alive will
be of great interest to the Foundation.”
“I look forward to examining the specimens. We’re
kind of backed up right now, but we’ll get around
to it. You know, saving the best for last and
all.” researcher Breen responds. “There’s a
delicate matter that we’re attending to at the
moment. It should be resolved soon.” Breen looks
down at the clipboard he’s holding and frowns.
“I’ve got to go, but I’ll keep you updated.”
After a few days, Breen calls Dr. Sanders into his
lab. “You’re going to want to see this. It’s those
weird egg-type specimens you brought back from
the caverns. They’ve been designated SCP-1124.”
“Perfect, I’ve been dying to
know what those things are,”
Sanders says as he enters the lab.
“Do you mind if I record this,
just so I have something to send back
to my superiors at the Foundation?”
Breen agrees, and the two SCP researchers
begin their analysis of the clear orbs.
“So, they’re not made of glass like we originally
thought,” Breen begins. “We actually aren’t
entirely sure what these things are made of.
They definitely have the shape of an egg,
but the solid, clear outer layer makes me think
that they are more like carrying containers than
anything else. See, look.” Bree grabs the
top of one of the orbs and pulls it off.
There is a satisfying pop, like a Champagne
cork exploding out of the top of a bottle.
Dr. Sanders looks at the lid and then watches as
Breen puts the top back on the orb. “But that’s
not the weirdest part,” Breen says. “Take a look
at what’s inside.” Sanders leans over the opened
orb and looks into it. The creature inside
looks like a silver squid. It does not move,
but Sanders gets an uneasy feeling as if there is
something inherently dangerous and evil about the
metallic squids. “Come over here; I have some laid
out on the table for you to examine,” says Breen.
They walk over to another lab bench where
there are several creatures laid out.
Breen uses forceps to move the appendage of
one of the creatures. The limbs are segmented,
but there is no sign of eyes or a mouth as far as
Sanders can tell. “What are they?” asks Sanders.
“No idea, but watch this.” Breen picks up one of
the creatures with the forceps by the tentacle.
Sanders expects the arm to be flexible
and rubbery like a squid's, but instead,
they are stiff and rigid like a knife. When Breen
pics up the limb, the entire creature moves with
it like a statue. He pulls out a scalpel and
looks at Dr. Sanders. “Watch this,” he says.
Nothing happens as Breen presses the blade
against SCP-1124’s exoskeleton. He pushes harder,
and harder, and harder. Eventually, the scalpel
breaks, and the blade clangs to the floor.
“We haven't been able to break the shell, so we
don’t know exactly what’s inside. But I have a
few other ideas on how to crack this puppy open,”
Breen says with a smile. He pulls out a blow torch
and begins blasting the metallic squid with the
flame. There is no effect. Breen then brings
out a vat of liquid nitrogen. He picks up one of
the creatures and places it inside the canister.
When he pulls it out, the instance
of SCP-1124 is covered in frost.
Breen grabs a hammer off of one of
the lab tables and smashes it down
onto the shell. There is a clank as if
the hammer struck a metal pole. Breen
shakes his hand, which is now throbbing from the
reverberations sent through the hammer on impact.
“Maybe they aren’t alive at
all,” chuckles Dr. Sanders.
“Maybe they’re just figurines
or statues or something.”
“That’s what I was starting
to think, too,” replies Breen.
“What a waste of time,” Sanders says. He hocks
a loogie and spits at SCP-1124 in disgust.
The spit hits the outer shell and slowly begins
to run down the side. Dr. Sanders and Breen take
a seat at one of the tables. “It seemed like those
things were going to hold some real promise. Maybe
even get us off of this rock,” Dr. Sanders says
as he lights a cigarette and offers one to Breen.
“Yeah, the orbs and whatever is
inside of them are real duds,”
Breen commiserates. “Guess
it's time to focus on—.”
Suddenly one of the arms of the creature
that Dr. Sanders spat on begins to move.
“Did you see that?” Breen yells. “The
squid-thing, it just moved its arm!”
Breen and Sanders run to the lab table where
the instance of SCP-1124 slowly stretches its
tentacles as if feeling its surroundings
to get a better idea of its location.
Breen reaches out to touch
one of the metallic arms.
“Stop! Don’t touch it!” Dr. Sanders yells.
But it’s too late. The creature makes contact
with Breen’s skin. It instantly comes alive.
All of its tentacles are now moving
freely; the ends have sharpened tips.
The creature jerks one of its tentacles, slashing
Breen’s neck. Blood splatters across the room,
covering several other instances of SCP-1124. As
the blood touches them, they slowly come to life.
Their tentacles move all around as if
searching for the source of the bodily fluid.
Dr. Sanders shrieks for help. He sprints towards
the door. But before he can reach it, one of the
instances of SCP-1124 launches itself off a table
and impales its spiked arms into Sander’s back.
He screams in pain. Tears fall down the sides of
his cheeks as his hand slams against the glass
door that leads out of the lab. The creature
climbs up his back and over his head. It then
pries Dr. Sander’s mouth open and squirms down
his throat. As he is torn apart from the inside
by the metal tentacles of SCP-1124, his hand
slides down the door leaving a bloody handprint.
The audio recorder continues to
run in the lab. It picks up the
unsettling sounds of metal on metal and the
guttural screeches of the SCP-1124 creatures.
The glass door leading from the lab
to the rest of the ILYENA facility
shatters. Instances of SCP-1124 come
streaming out. The researchers at
the base have no idea that one of the most
dangerous SCPs the Foundation has ever faced
is now squirming along the halls of the facility,
looking for hosts to lay their eggs inside.
Years go by without any communication from ILYENA.
The Foundation assumes something has gone wrong,
but that was the point of setting up the
base on a faraway planet in the first place.
If an experiment got out of
hand or a dangerous SCP escaped,
the only people who would be in danger
were the agents and Class-D personnel
at ILYENA. It was a much safer alternative to
conducting these sorts of experiments on Earth.
The O-5 council redacts much of the information
on ILYENA and the research happening there.
The file is buried deep within the Foundation’s
database and forgotten. That is until several
years later when a ship from ILYENA crash
lands just outside an Air Force Base in Nevada.
“General! We’ve just received word from the
Foundation that one of our deep space research
vessels has crashed in the desert not too far
from here. The O-5 Council has asked that we
send a team to recover whatever is on board.
Apparently, it came from a base called ILYENA.”
“Never heard of it,” responds
the General. “Alright, let’s
send a task force to go retrieve
whatever is on board that thing.”
A group of SCP scientists and agents are
dispatched to carry out reconnaissance and
containment procedures for the crashed ILYENA
rocket. There is very little information on
what to expect as most of the reports and
documents about ILYENA are classified.
As the team sets out to recover
whatever is on board the rocket,
a reptile-like creature that has remained
dormant at the base for the last 30 years
twitches. No one notices the slight
movement even though this SCP is heavily
guarded and deemed one of the biggest
threats to humanity’s very existence.
“General, we’ve reached the crash site,” one
of the agents radios back to the airbase.
“The rocket is in rough shape, but the cargo
hold seems to be intact. We are opening it now.”
The extraction team uses welding torches to
cut through the outer lock of the capsule.
They pull back the door and peer inside.
“What are those things?” one of the agents asks.
As the flashlight moves across the cargo hold,
the team can see hundreds of glassy orbs packed
tightly into the space within the rocket.
“Well, let’s get them back to base so they
can be analyzed,” says the team leader.
Using recommended containment procedures, the
extraction team carefully removes each of the
orbs and loads them onto a transport helicopter.
All of the agents wear protective hazmat suits,
and no one is allowed to directly
come into contact with the orbs.
Once the helicopter is loaded, it takes off and
returns to the Air Force Base. The chopper lands,
and a team of researchers load
the orbs into a containment pod
which is then brought immediately
to the lab for analysis.
“I finally found some information on what
ILYENA was and what these things might be,”
the lead scientists at the base
informs the other researchers.
“It took a lot of digging, but I’m
pretty sure the orbs are classified
as SCP-1124. As far as I can tell, they
contain some kind of squid-like statue,
but the information from ILYENA is kind of
spotty. Not exactly sure what happened up there.”
The other researchers listen as they’re briefed.
“We’re pretty much starting from scratch here,
so be careful and use proper containment
procedures as if you’re dealing with an
unknown SCP,” the lead scientist
finishes. The researchers nod to
indicate they’ve heard what their
boss has said and then get to work.
Deep underground, the reptilian creature still
lies dormant. There are slight fluctuations in
the thermal readings in its containment chamber,
but the beast does not seem to be awake. The
SCP agents on duty note in their log that the
thermal sensors might need to be recalibrated.
Two researchers enter a cleanroom
and lock themselves inside.
They have brought in one of the
SCP-1124 orbs for further analysis.
As the researcher who is holding the orb walks
towards the table in the middle of the room, he
accidentally trips. The other researcher reaches
out and tries to grab his colleague but misses.
The orb falls to the ground; the researcher
scrapes his leg on the corner of the table.
He doesn't notice the tear in his protective
suit where a small trickle of
blood drips onto the floor.
“Ow, that really hurt,” the
researcher says, rubbing his shin.
The orb roles in a circle on the
ground; it slowly comes to a stop
right on top of a drop of blood
from the injured researcher.
The orb begins to shudder. Both of the scientists
look on in shock as it rolls along the floor,
banging into the containment chamber
walls as if looking for a way
out. The researchers jump to
their feet and run after the orb.
One of the scientists grabs the orb off the
ground and holds it tightly in both hands.
Suddenly, a hole appears in the orb's
surface. The researchers look at one another,
their eyes wide in terror. The researcher holding
the orb puts his hand over the hole to cover it.
He instantly recoils in pain as
something stabs him from within.
A metallic tentacle appears through the
hole in the orb, followed by a creature
with a squid-like body. The creature remains
motionless, sensing the room around him.
The scientist not holding the orb races
towards the storage closet to find
something to cover the hole with. The
other researcher remains motionless,
hoping that the creature will
just go back into its container.
Without warning, the creature launches itself at
the faceplate of the researcher holding the orb.
It smashes through the protective shielding
and enters the mouth of the researcher.
The other scientist screams in terror. He runs
out of the containment chamber and slams down
the button to activate the failsafe to prevent a
containment breach. The room begins to fill with
mist and triflic acid. Alarms sound in the lab;
other SCP personnel come rushing in. They watch in
horror as the head of the researcher with SCP-1124
inside of him starts to expand. Blood begins to
pour out of his nose, eyes, and ears. Then with
a gruesome pop, the researcher’s head explodes.
The researchers lean closer to the window
to get a better look at what’s happening.
They scan the room when suddenly the instance
of SCP-1124 slams into the observation glass.
The researchers jump back in surprise. A crack
runs the length of the observation window.
At the same time the alarms are
going off in the research lab,
different alarms sound deep within the facility.
Sensors have picked up a huge jump in thermal
energy in the reptilian creature’s chamber,
along with the movement of its tail and limbs.
Armed SCP Foundation agents run towards the
containment chamber. But when they are only
a few feet away, the blast door is forced off
its hinges and slams against the far wall of
the complex. The containment team screeches to
a halt as SCP-682 slowly lumbers out of its cell
and shakes its body. The creature locks
eyes with the agents, who are frozen
in shock. It curls back its lips to reveal
razor-sharp teeth; saliva falls to the floor.
“Open fire!” one of the agents yells.
They fire a barrage of bullets at SCP-682,
but they seem to have no effect. The
creature stalks towards the agents
and uses its claws and teeth to tear them apart.
SCP-682 runs through the facility,
killing every living thing in its path.
It bursts out into the sunlight, where it
sniffs the air. It then sprints toward the
high-density fence and bursts through it
as if it was nothing more than cobwebs.
SCP-682 runs in the direction
of the crashed ILYENA rocket.
A battalion of agents is deployed to stop SCP-682,
but the monster quickly destroys anyone and
anything in its path. It seems to be on a mission,
and nothing will stop it. When SCP-682 reaches
the rocket, it consumes the entire research
team that is there examining the spacecraft.
It then begins sniffing around the area and climbs
into the cargo hold. It is looking for something.
Mobile Task Force Iota-5 approaches the rocket in
two teams. The first is on the ground in armored
vehicles; the second is in a helicopter. They have
a plan. It seems that SCP-682 is looking for the
orbs that were inside the rocket. For some reason,
they are incredibly important to SCP-682, and it
will stop at nothing to find them. SCP-682 is
acting like a mother searching for a lost child.
Mobile Task Force Iota-5 has brought one of
the SCP-1124 orbs with them in hopes they can
lure SCP-682 back to its containment chamber.
When the first team approaches in the chopper,
SCP-682 stops its search. The creature
sniffs the air and spots the helicopter.
“Uh oh, I think he’s spotted us,” says the pilot.
The ground force opens fire on SCP-682,
but the creature does not seem interested
in them. Instead, SCP-682 remains fixated
on the helicopter as if it knows there is
an orb on board. The creature leaps off
the rocket and begins running towards the
helicopter. The pilot turns the chopper
and flies away with SCP-682 in pursuit.
They make it back to the air force base just ahead
of SCP-682. One of the agents jumps out of the
helicopter with the SCP-1124 orb in his hands.
He races towards a mobile containment chamber,
where he places the orb at the
far end before turning to get out.
When he looks up, SCP-682
is standing in the doorway.
Its chest heaves up and down. Its eyes are
wild. The SCP agent raises his gun and fires.
SCP-682 snarls and leaps into the containment
chamber. The whole thing shakes as the agent is
torn apart. His gunshots and screams are silenced
as the door to the containment chamber shuts.
The fiasco known as the “Grey Dragon Incident”
is an embarrassment to the Foundation.
The O-5 Council has everyone involved terminated.
SCP-682 is secured in a new containment facility
far away from SCP-1124. And the mysterious orbs
are placed in their own containment chamber
and hidden away from the
world. The working hypothesis
is that SCP-1124 are the eggs of SCP-682,
but further tests will need to be done.
And since both of these SCPs are extremely
dangerous, these experiments might need to
be conducted on a faraway planet. Perhaps
it is time for the SCP Foundation to revisit
ILYENA once again. Let’s just hope, this
time, they don’t bring anything else back…
Now watch “SCP-682 - Ways SCP Foundation Tried
to Kill Hard To Destroy Reptile” or check out
“How to Kill SCP-682 - Theories and Ideas”
for more on the monster we all know and fear!